the c-span networks bring you long-form
public affairs programming from the
nation's capital
c-span created by cable um what i would
at least discuss
well you're right i'm from down south oh
god's mom and i'm your mother
boring
and who said politics couldn't be fun
ladies and gentlemen soups and super
villains we have the second last episode
of the season setting us up for
a giant confrontation between the boys
and hashtag team homefront
and there is a lot to talk about
including the fate of black noir
lamplighter and of course which porn is
my favorite also special shout out to
this video's sponsor
brave maze vegetarian pride lasagna for
when you're feeling gay now get your
strap on on i mean
strap on in because here we go first off
this episode has to be the most
political yet
it begins with a segment about how one
man is slowly radicalized by
far right propaganda they paint this guy
out to be the stereotypical white male
incel he lives alone with his mother is
ignored by
women and every waking moment is
surrounded by radio television and news
that depicts the problem with society as
super villain
immigrants basically it gives this guy
someone to blame his shitty life on
stormfront knows the power of making
people rally against a common enemy
a common enemy rallies the base i wonder
where she picked that
up the radio host he listens to sounds
exactly like alex jones he's known for
his conspiracy theories
i don't like him putting chemicals in
the water that turned the friggin frogs
gay
fought news is a substitute for fox news
which propagates right-wing talking
points like
more funding for counter-terrorism the
police and border security to counter
the encroaching
super villain threat just substitute
super villain for immigrant and you see
what the writers of the boys are doing
here this is one of the most escaping
portrayals of right-wing politics in
america
in the credits this character's name is
tommy peterson they could have just
called him tommy why add this last
name peterson unless it's a not a
controversial political figure
jordan peterson who is known for his
following of predominantly young white
men
there's also some fun news bits here
like stormfront defending a fan who
attacked a homeless immigrant or
congresswoman newman's college dance
videos resurfacing as i outlined in my
last video victoria newman is based off
real-life congresswoman alexandra
ocasio-cortez who also had a bunch of
her college dances go viral
at the convenience store there are tons
of super product placement like a train
peeps
frosted eight trains cereal starlight
skin care products and my favorite
black noir shaving kit it's here tommy
thinks he sees the eyes of the
convenience store clerk
glow believing him to be one of those
super villain immigrants he's heard so
much about and with online memes saying
immigrate legally or die and stormfront
on the tv
saying it's up to us we have to make our
voices heard
tommy takes matters into his own hand
and kills the clerk who's not a soup at
all
later stormfront and homelander will say
how this was a tragedy they'll make a
donation and
send thoughts and prayers they know that
their rhetoric is riling up a base of
hate and how their actions will do
nothing to stop further attacks
lamplighter the boys in victoria go over
the story they're going to tell at the
house judiciary committee how vat was
injecting compound v
to patients at sage grove and committing
terrible crimes
including murder but victoria says they
need the full picture they can't just
know what vat did they need to know why
they did it
starlight meets with her mother at a
local coffee shop she's not just pissed
at her mother for being overbearing but
that her beliefs growing up were all a
lie
she used to be a passionate member of
capes for christ but now it's all
[ __ ] the good guys don't win the bad
guys don't get
punished what we do means nothing
it's just all for money mother tells her
that the two of them should just get
away from everything before they're tear
gassed and starlight gets the crap
kicked out of her by black noir
the boys are tasked with their missions
frenchie will make sure newman stays
alive
butcher gets sidetracked with a call
that his father is dead and huey is
tasked with watching over lamplighter
who loves
porn lots and lots of porn huey and
lamplighter talk about how their lives
have gotten sidetracked
now look at me sitting on the sidelines
while the real heroes are they're doing
the [ __ ] huey feels like he's useless
turning into his father who did nothing
after his mom
died he's just like a [ __ ] in one of
lamplighter's pornos
actually you're worse you're the cuck
fluffer
homelander and stormfront kiss publicly
for the first time at one of their
rallies he's totally on team stormfront
after she told him the truth about her
past
he like stormfront wants to get the
people on their side so that their plan
of creating an army of supes to bolster
the white man
can prevail we need more compound v
absolutely
we need more soups and it's here we
learned starlet is apprehended for
aiding the boys in the murder of
translucent she's been held on vat's
42nd floor in a special cell where she's
unable to use her power with the news of
starlight's imprisonment huey convinces
lamplighter to save her from vaught
tower
after all they're not cucks right and
butcher finds denathor i mean
his father isn't dead at all fun fact
actor carl urban who plays butcher was
also in the lord of the rings he played
eomer butcher and the old man don't get
along
largely because it was the way his
father brought him up which led to his
brother lenny's death
in the comics lenny died in a bus
accident in 1986
however in the show father says lenny
shot himself he was an overbearing
father and he believes that butchers
should be thanking him for preparing him
for the harsh world
it's a [ __ ] world out there you can't
rely on no one like yourself
you are the saint or you swim but that's
exactly the opposite of what billy needs
to learn especially when it comes to the
boys he needs to trust them and the
scene ends with father suggesting
lenny's death was triggered by billy
leaving him
something he doesn't take too kindly to
homelander tells stormfront that it's a
mistake to keep starlight alive
as we saw two episodes ago stormfront
seems to have some sort of use for
starlight
you're gonna be a big help to me
stormfront sees a small child which
reminds her of her own and this is one
of those rare times we actually see her
express her true feelings
this compels homelander to introduce her
to his son ryan as they solely work to
remove him from becca
to create their own weird superhero
family i want us to be a family
elena and maeve break up after she saw
what maeve did with the airplane she
can't be with her anymore and it
frustrates mape spiraling her into some
meaningless sex with some dudes
this is not lesbian this is not on brand
mother's milk and grace mallory visit dr
vogelbaum the scientist we saw in season
one who raised homelander in the vaught
lab they want him to do the right thing
and testify against vaught but he won't
because he knows it would put his family
in danger
but some things are more important than
the right thing this is a direct
contrast to butcher's approach who
visits vogelbaum a bit later and in
total butcher fashion he just
runs over the grass with his car butcher
tells vogelbaum that he'll kill his
entire family if he doesn't testify
really hitting home what grace mallory
said to him earlier i have no doubt
you'd be happy with that unending cycle
of brutality
not only did vogelbaum imprison his wife
butcher's amp to take out his rage on
someone he sees
parallels with his father both men
restrict parents going above and beyond
in their cruelty to their children to
prepare them for a harsh world
grace offers mother's milk a flight to
nicaragua with his family which he says
he'll do when the job is done
but as grace says the job is never done
this scene
really surprised me mother's milk has
been wanting to be reunited with his
family
all season but my guess is that they're
setting something up for his character
here
frenchie and kimiko watch after newman
as protesters rage outside her apartment
chanting send her back
it's as if pulled straight from the
headlines when aoc spoke
out against similar chants against
fellow congresswoman ilhan
omar but really this scene is about
bonding between frenchie and kimiko
kimiko opening up to teach him his first
word of sign language
and of course its gun fresca's for all
what appears to be alistera dana's
birthday the head of the church of the
collective eagle the archer the man who
helped the deep when he was rock bottom
drunk at a water park in sandusky ohio
has been excommunicated from the church
after he refused to cut off his mother
in retaliation the church released a sex
tape of him where he hunts and chases
someone wearing a deer costume hey
whatever you're into also if you search
soup porn.com it just takes you to the
boys website so
don't try guys adana says things are
looking good for getting them both back
into the seven and with starlight black
noir and shockwave who i'm not sure was
officially signed into the seven just
yet
looking like they're out this could be
their time ryan loves to create
stop-motion lego animations of popular
films like the blind side and
terms of endearment and it's here we
really see stormfront
intruding into the family telling ryan
they can do cool things like
sleepovers watch homelanders violent
movies and trips to vaughtland
becca doesn't like this telling
homelander that the best thing for ryan
is him to grow up with his mother
something homelanders should know
because he never grew up with one
homelander agrees but in true homeland
or fashion turns ryan against her
showing him how his entire life was a
lie everything around him
is fake the house the community is his
mother fake
too he and stormfront take off with ryan
leaving becca alone and it's pretty
obvious she'll be turning to butcher
next episode for help
lamplighter reveals the real reason for
helping huey break into vaught he wants
to kill himself in front of his own
statue which they've taken away
these subsequent flames turn on the
sprinkler system which allows starlight
enough power to break free from her cell
but during her escape she's attacked by
black noir it's maeve however who comes
and saves the day by
feeding black noir and almond joy which
he's allergic to
it makes this scene a few episodes ago
all the better fun fact the actor who
plays black noir actually has a tree nut
allergy
which was the inspiration for this and
we see a part of his face for the first
time
who would have thought that black noir
was black huey ends up saving
starlight's mother she remembers him
from the belief festival way back in
season one and when he's finally
reunited with starlight his face is like
i'm not a [ __ ]
and the final scene is just a glorious
head-exploding mess as dr vogelbaum
prepares to testify before the judiciary
committee his head along with countless
others explode and stormfront in
homelander watch on
not really as concerned as those around
them i'd put money on this being the
work of cindy who we saw explode brains
last episode she was also likely the
soup working for stormfront to take out
agent raynor way back in episode 1. it's
not exactly clear if homelander was in
on it but this stinks of stormfront and
stan
edgar now i looked all throughout the
background actors to see if cindy was
there and i couldn't find her so i'm
wondering if she's in the room at all
can she use her powers through a
television or is she somehow hidden in a
vent or
perhaps watching through the window
whatever it is the boys plans to stop
vaught for good have come to a crashing
halt
as their two key witnesses have died
that's it for today's video only one
more episode of the boys left so make
sure you've liked and subscribed so
you're notified as soon as my season 2
video drops
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter or instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy's home